we bring in Adrian wood general Sookie
from the mothership who had a great day
yesterday breaking all this news watch
thanks for joining us let me start with
the Cavs strategy what were the Cavs
trying to do and did they accomplish
that yesterday hi Dan they wanted to get
younger more athletic and they wanted to
sort of balance the the chance to
continue to improve this team in the
short term around the Bron James but
also bring in some players that even if
LeBron James left in free agency that
they could go forward with and that they
have under contract so they do that with
Jordan Clarkson Larry Nance and Rodney
hood who's a restricted creation but
they would be able to control his future
this coming summer and that was a big
part of the moves they made was to do
those and then also keep that Brooklyn
pick from the Kyrie Irving trade which
will be a lottery pick and really the
best asset the organization has going
forward tell me what the Lakers did and
did they accomplish what they meant to
do well they needed to start to get
money off for 2018 free agency 2019 free
agency and Jordan Clarkson was a player
who they thought they might have to with
different points attached draft but to
get someone to take him they end up with
Cleveland's first-round pick on 2018 in
the deal and no four for the Lakers you
know they want to be involved with
LeBron James and Paul George this summer
but they're also realistic they become
more realistic in that they can't be all
or nothing and creatin see this year
that if those players may not look at
the lake organization and say hey
they're ready to win that their young
guys have evolved enough that if we sign
offer one of us signs up like or a
contender but maybe in 2019 a class of
Jimmy Butler Kawhi Leonard klay Thompson
a potential classic those players would
look at the Lakers and say hey we can
start winning with the young guys they
have and uh that's kind of the line the
Lakers are trying to balance not
and create heat do you think the Cavs
help the Lakers get LeBron James with
yesterday's moves here's how Cleveland
saw that and obviously they discussed it
internally while they were looking at
the deal they knew this you look back in
history when LeBron left from Cleveland
to Miami and then back from Miami to
Cleveland both times those organizations
scrambled in late June early July to
create the cap space just for the
opportunity to get LeBron and they knew
that the league's would be able to do
that that if they had seen where they
knew LeBron was coming they would have
been able to make trades and deals to
clear the cap space and so if it wasn't
the Cavs doing it with this one that
somebody else was going to do it and and
they looked at the landscape the players
available and they said listen the best
players available to us and a deal that
you have in a play for the Lakers and
for us to pass on that just for the
occurrence of what it would look like
like that didn't measure up to saying we
can't get better elsewhere so let's do
this deal with the Lakers they
originally were talking about Clark's
and then they expanded it to Larry Nance
and then they said hey look let's get
done it forget with the athletes of this
yeah the Isiah Thomas portion of this so
you get him he's not your prototypical
point guard but you how does that mix or
how is that going to mesh with Lonzo
ball it's gonna be really interesting
and how you know I think part of the
thought in where the Cavs was he
struggled but he was struggling coming
off of really serious injury that was
going to take time and it was always
going to take time but I think all the
other strife around there I think
amplified the issues I was having with
coaching staff with some of his
teammates and now you go to LA now
wisel's been out a while and he hasn't
played in a few weeks but there Isiah
Thomas is a rental for them he's there
just for the rest of the season and
he'll be gone so they're going to
continue to focus on the ball being in
lonzo's hands and he's out there you
know guk wallet has mentioned maybe
playing them together Isaiah is going to
have to adjust to probably an entire
view here where he's not the primary
ball handler
he doesn't have it like he did in Boston
and that's listen in a contract year
were you trying to get your one big free
agent score as an NBA player
there's no question it's frustrating for
Isaiah he had planned that he would be
maybe a near max player a max player and
that's not reality anymore and it'll be
interesting to see what part of the
place is going to be for him this summer
how much healthier how much better does
he get this year to show people that
that he's a wallet that's been over a
long-term deal woods great job yesterday
always great to talk to you thanks for
spending some time with us Dan thanks
for having me as always that's a Adrian
we'll turn around ski from the
mothership for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]